hello and good morning rescue teams have
been working through the night in turkey
and Syria desperately hoping to reach
survivors still traps beneath flattened
concrete and Twisted Metal more than 4
000 people are now known to have died
with that number expected to rise
significantly and with whole
neighborhoods destroyed many thousands
more are injured and homeless in
freezing conditions now in Syria the
earthquake is being described as a
crisis within a crisis a disaster
inflicted on a population already
traumatized by 12 years of war these are
the latest live pictures coming into us
from the Turkish city of the abacar a
city of a million people where hundreds
of buildings have been entirely
destroyed by the earthquake
neighborhoods flattened and the rescue
effort as you can see continues a pace
to try and find anyone who may well be
alive beneath the rubble
now the first earthquake with a
magnitude of 7.8 struck at 17 minutes
past four on Monday morning about 20
miles from the city of gaziantep close
to turkey's border with Syria
there were dozens of aftershocks and
then nine hours later it's 24 minutes
past one in the afternoon a second huge
Quake measuring 7.5 was recorded
pazarchik in the province of
the worst affected areas all along the
east Anatolian fault line
now in the abacar and in cities all
across the region including San leaf
osmania and Takia rescue Cruz some
Specialists some just local people
desperate to help have been spending the
past 24 hours since these earthquake
struck combing through the wreckage of
buildings to try and find anyone that
may have survived Turkish government
said that there were some 15 000 people
who've been injured that number is is
certain to rise in the coming days as we
see the scale of the devastation
hundreds of thousands have been made
homeless of course and have been put up
in local buildings such as universities
dormitories and other large facilities
now at the moment the death toll stands
at some four thousand seven hundred but
that number is certain to rise the
Turkish government says that 15 834 have
been injured but the real figure is
still unknown now many nations all
around the world including the UK the US
uh the Netherlands Croatia have been
sending Specialists teams after turkey
appealed for international assistance
and these pictures are from Istanbul
Airport from yesterday where hundreds
thousands of people turned up to
volunteer with the country's Disaster
Response agency ready to be sent
wherever they may be needed
well let's bring in our correspondent
Siobhan Robbins who's joining us now
from Istanbul good morning to you
Siobhan so just bring us the latest as
we understand it in terms of the rescue
effort and what's been happening in the
past day
well you've seen those pictures there
are crowds of people heading to airports
in Turkey trying to offer their support
and anything they can do to help those
who've been affected by these Quakes and
also International AIDS starting to come
as well but still because of the
widespread damage particularly here in
Turkey there are some communities which
are saying they simply do not have the
equipment they need at the moment to get
people out below the rubble people
saying that they can hear voices but
they cannot get through that and the
freezing conditions making the situation
even more difficult as the window to
free survivors following these
apocalyptic Quakes closes
slowly inch by inch the trapped are
released
survivors pulled from the rubble in
southern turkey
when darkness fell efforts continued
under Torchlight
each passing hour making the chance of
finding people alive more unlikely
across the border in Syria a similar
scene already scarred by a decade of war
the city of idlib was poorly equipped to
find those trapped under concrete
foreign
[Music]
followed hours later by a massive 7.5
trailer
a double blow twisting and mangling once
thriving cities
some of the Wounded have been taken on
military planes for treatment in
Istanbul
hundreds of volunteers have gathered at
the airport
45 Nations have offered help
the next 24 hours will be crucial
temperatures dropping below zero in some
areas the battle to save lives will
become even harder
well we know following massive
earthquakes like this the first 24 to 48
hours are critical for getting survivors
out alive but those freezing conditions
aren't just putting those stuck under
the rubble at extra risk it's also
people who've managed to escape from
their houses we know that thousands of
buildings have collapsed many people are
either sleeping in their cars or even
more dangerously having to huddle
together on the streets they are now at
risk of exposure as the freezing
temperatures continue
and Siobhan as you mentioned the weather
in the earthquake zone is very cold very
difficult for the rescue teams to work
in and of course difficult for those
people who've lost their homes and the
efforts to try and help them is coming
from all over the country and I know
that people have been driving from all
over from Istanbul where you are to try
and assist in any way they can you're
getting any sense of how it's being
organized at this point yet
well we know that 45 Nations have
offered support we know for example the
UK is sending uh more than 70 rescue
teams they're sending some dogs they're
sending specialist equipment that will
allow rescue teams here alongside the UK
to look beneath the rubble and also to
cut up the concrete that might be
trapping people below and then of course
as you say we've seen these pictures of
people going to airports uh you know
people living in the city here going
trying to offer support offer Aid donate
clothes do whatever they can to help
those who have either been left homeless
or are still stranded
okay Siobhan for now in Istanbul do
appreciate that thank you
now in the last half an hour we spoke to
our correspondent John Sparks who
managed to make it to osmania in Turkey
he sent us this report
I think an absolutely typical scene here
in this city city of 250 000 about a
hundred and fifty miles from the
epicenter of the earthquake we're on one
of the main boulevards in this city it's
called mustache here Boulevard and what
has happened here is that the earthquake
has brought down some buildings others
have been left standing let's go and
have we don't want to get in The
Rescuers way here let's just have a bit
of a look here what they've done is
brought in a couple of diggers they are
working on the remains of an apartment
building
they're taking Rubble
out from the side and what some of The
Rescuers told us was that they heard
voices overnight and they think there
may be up to 15 people
in the rubble let's come around again
and have a look I know the sun we are
fighting the sun here a little bit
see trying to
remove Rubble
from this site very difficult they've
got two diggers now working here
they think up to 15 people underneath uh
the rubble but what we've got here is a
sort of do-it-yourself collection of of
people city workers we've got members of
the fire department but no specialist
fire and rescue excuse me no Specialists
search and rescue officials they're
doing it themselves and here on the
other side we've got some people with
relatives who were in the building
itself it's very emotional scenes a
little bit earlier
see people here on the side waiting for
news of loved ones friends who are
inside this building the last time that
they saw them should we move around
again let's have a look
I mean they're working with real speed
now
I think the feeling here is they've got
to do something
it's very cold temperatures Sub-Zero
at night it's very cold still okay we're
just gonna move back we're being asked
to move back a little bit by the
by the organizers here yes understand
thank you
they're doing their best but it's
it is an emergency situation but it's
not being done
by emergency workers
there's people here from the fire
department they're doing the best they
can they don't have the search and
rescue personnel with their specialist
equipment
for example the the heat tracking
equipment that they use to try and
locate people under the rubble so
they're doing the best that they can and
that really is the situation in this
city as a whole
some buildings have been brought down
others haven't but really the local
authorities have been overwhelmed by
this at the moment
foreign
as we're watching your reporting we can
see that those guys there in the hard
hats seem to be a local Council
officials as you as you mentioned not
Specialists teams at all and we often
see that after the rubble is cleared
away that people try and move in um with
a more close search but you seem to be
saying that and it seems to be from the
pictures that we're seeing that they're
trying to clear as much of the debris as
possible because the building further
back they believe that they have heard
people who are trapped beneath it just
just describe for us the area because
you say that that building's come down
and the other buildings nearby are they
still standing
that's right that's right I mean it it
is
seemingly random how the earthquake has
has destroyed some buildings and left
others in seemingly perfect condition
and I mean this site here I'm going to
ask my colleague Olivia to pan back to
the building it's there's an apartment
building
tucked between two others with a very
large
pile of rubble behind it and we are
fighting the Sun a little bit to film
this but
what they are doing is they are
they've got these two diggers now at
work and they are trying to clear
the rubble the building itself has has
pancaked on itself it's come down it's
collapsed clearly a decision has been
made that the best thing to do
now
is to is to remove as much Rubble as
they can and it is
difficult to see how
any person people trapped underneath
that Rubble could survive for long under
there particularly in these temperatures
it's a difficult situation for them
again they're making they're making
decisions on the best available
information they have they don't have
search and rescue
teams here on site
the
Personnel here in The Red Jackets they
are from the local fire department
so they're doing what they can
actually see
I can see one or two search and rescue
people now on site taking a look and
that's that is the first time since
we've been here we've been here for
about an hour
what we were told
from one person was that there were four
people they thought trapped underneath
the rubble we were told by several
others that they were up to 15 they
heard voices overnight
they heard voices
but they haven't been able to to get
those people out and you you know you
can see why I mean
I'm looking at
10 12 meters of of rubble of slabs of
concrete collapsed in on
themselves it's difficult to see how
anybody would survive
the collapse of a building like this
very very difficult but you know they're
going to try they're here they need help
clearly
and you've got people on the other side
of the street desperate for news I mean
absolutely desperate
there are
people women on the other side crying
as they look on
clearly have friends or loved ones
inside this building and they are
waiting for news and this is the only
thing they can do the only thing they
can do is to come here and and watch
that must be
you know just
indescribably awful feeling
yes John absolutely helpless those
people on the other side of the street
there and and you mentioned you've been
there for about an hour I wonder if
you've had a chance to speak to to
anyone over there and and have they told
you uh what's been happening for the for
the past for the past day
just the briefest of the briefest of of
conversations and we got the immediate
sense that that local officials people
who work for the city here are really
overwhelmed by the situation we have
stopped on the way into the city on one
of the main boulevards that leads to the
Central Square but off the Central
Square we can see other streets where
again some buildings are standing others
have completely collapsed on themselves
so I think
I think it's fair to say that they are
they're really struggling with this I
mean let's take I'm going to ask yeah
let's
follow my colleague Olivia here I mean
we can see and
a lot
of Destruction here this is just one one
small part of the city and
they've got diggers here they've got the
equipment they do have the
infrastructure what they don't have is
the specialist Personnel to help them
deal with this and we saw them coming in
we flew in last night we saw search and
rescue teams from the Czech Republic
from the Netherlands from Turkey itself
but they need them here they need them
here quickly
I'm supporting there from Oz Mania let's
get the latest on what the UK government
is doing to help those affected by the
earthquakes I'm joined now by the
foreign office Minister Andrew Mitchell
Andrew Mitchell good morning to you and
thanks for being with us let's get
straight into the UK response we
understand that 76 experts have been
sent to Turkey here they arrived
no the uh they're leaving this morning
they'll arrive in daylight uh today they
were already at Birmingham Airport to
leave last night but the most important
early lesson of this is that the first
72 hours are critical and that means
close coordination with the Turkish
authorities who are themselves highly
competent and
um what we're sending is 76 Specialists
with the relevant equipment with four
sniffer dogs they will be operating in
daylight today under Turkish command and
I know that they're going to make a very
big impact when they get there along
with all the other International and
coordinated services that are deployed
and that coordination is important is
that why they're leaving today rather
than last night to make sure that it's a
joined up effort once they get in
country that's that's correct I mean
it's closely coordinated with the
Turkish authorities this is a an
appalling catastrophe in Turkey Turkey a
country that is very close to Britain
and which has also been host to uh
hundreds of thousands of refugees
millions of refugees who have gone there
so gazantium is a place I visited a few
years ago as part of the Syria relief
effort it's a densely populated area and
the calamitous effects of all of this
will will be quite extraordinary now
these experts that we're sending are Mr
Mitchell was that uh sent off our own
back or was this a direct request
because of course as you know you know
the area turkey does have expertise in
dealing with this kind of disaster no
the first thing we did when the news
broke yesterday morning was to speak to
the Turkish government to find out what
we could do to help we've learned a lot
of lessons since the earthquake in Haiti
where everyone piled in and the thing
didn't work well the coordination was
non-existent so we've learned that
lesson and we take our lead purely from
the Turkish government we find out what
the Turkish government wants and we do
our very best to supply it and the
Turkish government asked for the support
and that's why we are dispatching the 76
experts and the four sniffer dogs and
also deploying an emergency medical team
to help with the assessment but I can't
stress enough to your viewers that it is
the first 72 hours where we're 24 hours
plus into that now it is the first 72
hours when a coordinated response will
save the most lives and was that a
direct call between Rishi sunak and
president erdogan
I think it was between the foreign
office and the relevant authorities in
Turkey but the Prime Minister has
expressed very strong support and has
promised that Britain will be there by
turkey's side helping in at the
supporting time for the Turkish people
yeah you made that very clear Mr
Michelle I appreciate that I wonder what
what more do you think the UK government
can do to help
but what the UK government can do is to
respond to the needs that the Turkish
government set out and that is what
we're going to do we stand ready we're
in constant contact with their
coordinators and organizers and we stand
ready to help in any way that we can
do you have any concerns about the
amount of Aid that we're able to give
considering the fact that the aid budget
has been cut recently
well you're right V8 budget is under
very considerable strain but but Britain
always carves out a certain amount to
cope with humanitarian crises that is
what people in Britain expect us to do
Britain is always there uh first and in
strength to help when these appalling
catastrophes take place and we will be
there this time and the humanitarian
budget is is in in a way slightly
separate from the steady state
International Development budget and it
is there specifically to respond to
crises like these so this essentially
comes from an emergency fund rather than
the sort of overarching foreign aid
budget that we have no it's all part of
the same budget but there is within that
budget different areas of activity and
the humanitarian activity as we've seen
for example in the Horn of Africa with
the Dreadful drought that threatens so
many young lives there the humanitarian
budget is is very carefully coordinated
and set and it reacts to the need on the
ground you can never tell at the
beginning of the year what humanitarian
crises are going to take place and
therefore it has to be a flexible part
of what we do yeah and with the scale of
This Disaster Mr Mitchell and with your
calls recently to try and make sure the
a budget is increased do you think those
calls will be strengthened by what we've
seen I know only day into this disaster
well we are quite deliberately finding
ways of boosting the budget as you say
it was cut back some years ago it's now
at 0.55 it will return to 0.7 when the
economic circumstances allow but we have
other ways of sweating what the the
assets that we use the money that we
deploy but I want to stress that the
humanitarian approach is slightly
different because it has to be very
elastic because we never know what
humanitarian emergencies will emerge
during the course of the year yeah and
as we mentioned turkey does have
infrastructure to deal with this sort of
thing but of course across the border in
Northwest Syria there is no
infrastructure to deal with that how is
the UK going to be helping that region
that has been affected well you're quite
right the the the area of of Northern
Syria is is is is right in in the center
of all of this tragedy it's ungoverned
space part of the problem is it's very
difficult to get resources that are now
needed across the border from Turkey
partly because turkey's got its own
problems but also so because there's
only one Crossing place and we hope that
the UN will be able to negotiate
additional uh Crossing places we have
supported for many years the white
helmets in Syria which was a civil
defense grouping that helped people who
were caught up in the and joined the
Syrian crisis and Britain funds them and
we will continue to support them they
are active we know already in helping
with this Dreadful crisis and Britain
will continue to support them but to be
clear any Aid that goes into Northwest
Syria will have to come through turkey
through the gilbertosua crossing border
you're not planning on bringing Aid
directly into the northwest of Syria
it's very difficult to get Aid in we
will use anything we can to to get Aid
to people who are desperately needed and
we're talking uh and closely
coordinating with the United Nations but
if you look at the geography the the
weigh-in is from Turkey it's over that
border which is very constricted and
that's an additional problem at a
desperate time for people who've already
suffered so much and in Syria thank you
for that Mr Mitchell I know we don't
have much time with you but I do want to
ask you something about domestic
politics of course there's a mini
reshuffle that's going to be announced
in the next few hours uh if you asked to
be a chair person of the party would you
take it
the these are matters way above my pay
grade that matters for the Prime
Minister but uh I'm obviously very uh
honored to be doing the development job
in the foreign office and um I'm going
to get on today and in the days to come
focusing on this terrible tragedy in
turkey and Syria I appreciate that
Antonia denial Mr Mitchell I'll take it
from you but thank you very much for
your time this morning Andrew Mitchell
there thank you
all right let's just take you to the
latest picture from Northwestern Syria
there is the foreign minister Andrew
Mitchell was reporting this area has
been devastated of course hit by 12
years of Civil War ungoverned spaces as
our Andrew Mitchell described it not in
control of the regime out of Damascus
controlled by Rebel groups here but
thousands of people are known to have
lost their lives you can see the state
of the devastation buildings there that
have been bombarded by 12 years of Civil
War by a Russian and Syrian Jets and
helicopters now struck by the earthquake
many buildings that were already damaged
were already fragile of course with the
earthquake struck but some new buildings
have been put up to try and bring some
semblance of life back to those people
who are stuck in this area of
Northwestern Syria but put up very
quickly and some reports that put up not
in exactly
internationally compliant ways thus the
resulting Devastation that we're seeing
in in the northwest of Syria let's uh
bring in our Middle East correspondent
estabunkel who's joining us from
Jerusalem and it's still good to have
you with us this morning let's just pick
up on what we were seeing there in
Northwestern series Andrew Mitchell was
saying that the only way the UK is going
to get Aid in is if it goes through
turkey turkey's closed that border
crossing so it's going to be difficult
to get that help to those in Northwest
Syria that's needed
yeah I think this is is a real problem
um I've been speaking to contacts and
colleagues of ours in Syria and they
describe a really desperate situation
and one that I think we just don't know
the full reality of at the moment and I
mean if you look at the pictures that
are coming out of turkey they are
mirrored across the border in Northwest
Syria and I was listening to John
sparks's report uh on the ground in
Turkey I mean the few things he
mentioned for example the freezing
temperatures uh particularly overnight
well I mean that is affecting many of
the millions of refugees have been
displaced because of the civil war in
Syria so that is very concerning but
also he was making reference to some of
the expertise that the Turkish
government have on the ground in Turkey
through their own resources but also
through International Aid and you know
that's just not getting into Syria
I think it's going to be possible
through negotiation to perhaps get
humanitarian Aid into Northwest Syria so
medicine food shelters that kind of
thing and of course the British
government as one of many governments
including the Americans Canadians and
others around the world who fund the
white helmets will probably look to try
and channel more money and Aid through
that route but what is going to be
really difficult is how do you get the
expertise in there and as Andrew
Mitchell was saying the first 72 hours
are crucial to try and find anyone who's
still alive but one of the best ways of
doing that is using specialist equipment
whether it be sniffer dogs microphone
probes cameras heat sensors that kind of
stuff that needs the individuals who can
operate that kind of care to know
experience and training operating that
kit to be on the ground and literally in
the rubble in order to do that and I you
know I think it's gonna be very hard to
negotiate access as for them into
Northwest Syria and that means the
syrians are alone in this in many ways
quickly while we have you uh what's the
latest on reports that the Israeli
government is going to be sending some
help to Syria
well the Israeli government said that
they had been asked to send some help or
whether or not they would be prepared to
send some help it wasn't quite clear
where that request had come from but the
Israeli government said that they stood
ready to do so it would be an
extraordinary ton of events really
because Syria and Israel are engaged
regularly well Israeli jets in
particular fly regular bombing missions
over Syria particularly targeting
Iranian targets that are operating in
Syria and so to have a humanitarian
Mission coming from Israel into Syria to
help in some way would really be a big
sign that other political and security
factors are put to one side in order to
bring some sort of relief on the ground
thank you for that
if I have plenty more to come this
morning including I'll be speaking to
the executive director of a charity
coordinating support in Turkey
[Music]
hello there and welcome back our top
stories this morning Rescuers are
continuing to search for anyone who is
trapped beneath the rubble of collapsed
buildings in turkey and Syria
more than 4 700 people are now confirmed
to have died in the earthquakes
as Rescuers from around the world begin
to arrive in at Turkey including a team
of 76 Specialists from the UK
well our special correspondent Alex
Crawford has traveled too close to the
epicenter of the earthquake she sent us
this update from antakia
and virtually every building here has
been affected in some way and if I could
show 360 degree circle around here which
I can't because the signal is not strong
enough but there are damaged buildings
all around me behind me was an
eight-story Residential Building there
are just a few volunteers who are trying
to use pickaxes and their bare hands to
take out rubble and being told that you
can actually see if we can we'll try and
tentatively turn around here because on
this other building here they're hearing
voices as well
and they they try every now and again
they tell us to be quiet so that they
can use their small drills that's all
they've got to try and drill down
there's people shouting on the top of
that building
they've already taken out at least four
corpses this morning and they're
shouting now saying that they've heard
people beneath a lot of people in this
province feel that they have been
forgotten that they haven't received
help that they're still not getting help
we saw crowds of people looting one of
the supermarkets saying that they were
hungry they had nowhere to stay no homes
no food and crucially no help at the
moment we understand that the main
government hospital here has been
deserted of medical staff it's partially
a destroyed infrastructure has been has
been affected badly there are still
patients in there some of them have been
killed by the earthquakes others have
died because they haven't been looked
after in the interim since the
earthquake this area is still very
vulnerable to aftershocks and further
earthquakes and there have been multiple
through out the whole of the the turkey
Syria region
a special course Alex Crawford
atists from a turkey and from Syria
throughout the morning but now let's
turn to some of the days other news and
Sky News understands that the Prime
Minister Rishi sunak will reshuffle his
cabinets later changes will be limited
but will include a new uh chair to for
the conservative party after Nadeem
sahabi was sacked recently over his tax
Affairs it's bringing our political
correspondence Tamara Cohen who joins us
now tomorrow good to have you with us so
we are expecting the reshuffle soon it's
going to be a mini reshuffle and Andrew
Mitchell didn't quite rule himself out
of getting that job as chair
morning Kamali yes we are going to get a
cabinet reshuffle this morning Rishi
sunak's first since he came in in
October it's not going to be very
extensive but we're going to get a new
party chairman of course that position
has been vacant since Nadeem zahari was
sacked just over a week ago and that is
a key role because it is a very public
facing but it's also the person who has
to prepare the party to fight the next
election which is expected to happen
probably towards the end of next year so
he'll need to think hard about who in
his cabinet has that campaigning
experience and is a good communicator as
a result of that job being appointed we
expect other vacancies to come up which
may need to be filled we also expect
that Rishi sunak is going to divide up
the business and energy Department to
create a new energy Department with its
own Energy Secretary and perhaps merge
business with the trade Department Prime
Ministers are allowed to create any
departments they like and it usually
gives us a signal of what they think is
important Richie soon act told US during
the summer Leadership contest last year
that Britain's energy Independence was a
priority for him and he wanted someone
to be in charge solely of working on
that reducing Reliance on getting energy
from other countries where prices can of
course fluctuate as a result of events
like the war in Ukraine so we expect
some changes like that as ever with
reshuffles you get winners and losers
and you get people who are very
disappointed and may cause problems for
you down the track but really soon act
will by the time of his next cabinet
meeting which we expect to be later this
morning have a few new faces around his
top table and when we know who they are
you'll tell us about them tomorrow for
now thank you very much
also making news this morning uh BP has
reported its latest profit results that
they've more than doubled to a record
27.7 billion pounds last year now that
follows record profits announced by
shell off the back of surging Energy
prices driven of course by the Russian
invasion of Ukraine BP profits as we
said more than doubled this year to uh
23 billion pounds
now the search for Nicola bully is
entering its 11th day and it's including
now the use of specialized sonar
equipment at the river where she was
last seen the mother of two went missing
into Michael's on wire in Lancashire her
partner Paul Ansel has issued a fresh
appeal through police saying that
Nicholas two daughters desperately miss
her
the treasury in the Bank of England has
suggested that the UK should launch a
digital pound it would use technology
similar to that used by cryptocurrencies
like Bitcoin but the currency would be
backed by the state and be
interchangeable with cash
and the US military says that the
Chinese balloon is shot down over the
weekend was 200 feet tall or about the
height of a 20-story building It also
says that the sensor payload underneath
the site was the size of a regional
jetliner the U.S accuses China of spying
with the balloon but Beijing says it was
only monitoring weather patterns
now nurses are on the picket lines again
today after the NHS staged the biggest
strike in the services history yesterday
Health leaders say people should expect
an incredibly disrupted week let's bring
in our shiman Freeman Powell who's had a
picket line at University College
Hospital in central London for us this
morning good morning to you shimanso the
picket line continues and the strike
goes on into a second day
yes that's right more upheaval expected
in the NHS today as nurses go on strike
for this second time this week and of
course it follows yesterday which was
the biggest strike action day in the
nhs's history was it just nurses it was
paramedics ambulance workers call
handlers and so on that also went on
strike and today we're expecting more
disruption as nurses take to the picket
lines they will argue though they don't
want to be here they're being forced to
the picket Lines by the governments as
they have also accused the government of
being on strike itself after refusing as
far as the nurses are concerned to get
around the negotiation table and discuss
pay now nurses had been asking for that
19 pay rise but had said that they were
willing to meet the government halfway
on this one thing they're not prepared
to budge on them is negotiation for this
financial year they want the financial
year of 2022 and 2023 to be a negotiated
but the government said that they would
rather look to the Future and that 19
that the nurses are asking for is
unaffordable and of course as I've said
it's not just the nurses that they have
to consider they've got to think about
teachers who are striving as well as
well as transportation workers other
civil servants and public sector workers
too all of whom have already been taken
strike action or have said that they
plan to do so we have actually heard
this morning as well about postal
workers and their strike action they had
been planning to walk out on the 16th
and 17th of this month but they've had
to call off that strike action because
of a legal challenge by Royal Mail now
they say that they are still balloting
members for strike action in the future
but that strike action on the 16th and
17th has so far been called off so as I
say another day of disruption for the
NHS and another day that the government
is being called on to start negotiating
data with public sector workers on pay
and working conditions
we have you and I know you're on a
picket line there and thanks for
bringing us the news about those postal
workers but I wonder from the nurses the
healthcare staff that you've been able
to speak to this is the second day of
the biggest strikes that is in the
history of the NHS what are they saying
to you about the fact that they find
themselves still off the wards still not
caring for people which is the whole
reason they went into the profession
it would necessarily that they have been
forced to strike and that's because of
pay and because of working conditions
the nurses I've spoken to have said that
because of the low pay and the working
conditions that many of their colleagues
have been forced into other professions
and that means that for the ones that
stay behind they're facing um huge
amounts of pressure in on their workload
they're having to deal with the
understaffing and on top of that they
say that they've been faced with
real-time cuts to their salaries because
of a decade of cuts to the NHS many of
them say that they don't want to be on
picket lines they would rather be
dealing with patients but as it stands
something needs to be done to address
not only pay but the conditions that
patients are facing as well and in terms
of the NHS and what it means for the NHS
of course we're already speaking about
this backlog of around seven million
people people waiting for operations and
appointments and we've already heard
that because of strike action over the
last couple of weeks and months that
around 80 000 planned appointments and
procedures have been canceled now NHS
leaders are saying that people should
still go to their planned appointments
if they haven't been told it's been
canceled but of course this is huge
disruption to the NHS
okay uh shiman there outside a hospital
thank you very much for that reporting
let's return now to our top story this
morning and this is the scene of
Devastation in the city of maras in the
southeast of turkey a city of some 1.1
million people and as you can see again
buildings entirely flattened by
yesterday's huge earthquakes two major
earthquakes at 7.8 magnitude and 7.5 and
in between those two major Quakes which
was shallow resulting in all this
Devastation there were dozens and dozens
of aftershocks in fact there was even an
earthquake in central turkey of 5.6
magnitude yesterday but this season the
Southeastern city of Castleman maras
there are many other cities that of
course have been affected throughout the
region solefa and Takia where are Alex
Crawford is osmania where John Sparks
was reporting from this morning an all
report a similar scene of Devastation
and people now uh just about 24 hours on
from the initial Quake trying
desperately to bring anyone out alive
from collapsed buildings
well governments and Aid organizations
from all around the world have been
rushing to provide assistance as rescue
teams race to find survivors who may
well be trapped in turkey and Syria
let's bring in now evident I don't uh
co-founder of the Turkish charity that
coordinates the supply in times of
Crisis needs map uh evident adiane thank
you very much for being with us just
tell us understand that you are in Adana
tell us about the situation where you
are
yeah yeah actually I am right now in
London uh yesterday we were as a team in
Adana Adana is supposedly uh like in a
better condition
s
you know like there are lots of needs
for rescue skills so the situation is
like anything
hello
yes and I will apologize to viewers I'm
sure uh there'll be understanding of the
fact that uh connections uh via
telephones are quite difficult at this
time is a disaster area you said that
you're in antakia uh Alex Crawford is in
that city as well she showed us uh
pictures of uh many collapsed buildings
what have you seen this morning as
you've as you've been there
I I apologize uh apologize uh um
everyone I don't think we can we can
stick with this line obviously it's
entirely understandable that that's
difficult and keeping the connection if
we can establish it in a better way
we'll come back to you but uh thank you
very much evident Adon from needs map
and best luck in all your work thank you
now as we continue our coverage of
yesterday's two major Quakes there are
reports of yet another earthquake a
magnitude 5.7 earthquake in the east of
turkey that's according to seismologists
uh 5.7 magnitude not nearly as big as
those ones from yesterday but still
significant and shows that the seismic
activity in and around this region
continues the East Anatolian fault line
was the line where the major earthquakes
happened yesterday a slip strike causing
all this Devastation but now another
earthquake has been recorded 5.7
magnitudes only just happened so of
course we get more detail of any damage
that's been caused by that we'll bring
it to you as soon as we can
now the challenges facing efforts to
help people affected by the earthquakes
in Syria continue and compound I'll be
speaking to the head of the Syrian Arab
red crescent after this short break
hello there and welcome back uh you're
watching Sky News and our continuing
live coverage of the earthquake it's
affected us both turkey and Syria this
is the latest camera that we have
positioned in the Turkish city of the
Abacus as the rescue effort there
continues the Turkish government saying
that more than 4 700 people are now
known to have died as a result of those
earthquakes and in the last half an hour
a third earthquake has been recorded of
5.6 magnitude in the east of turkey more
details on that to Camp 5.7 sorry
magnitude more details on that's to come
as we get them but the rescue effort has
continued all through the night and well
into this morning as some 15 000 people
are now known to have been injured
Turkish government also telling us that
some 15
000 people have been sent to try and
help with the rescue effort now
dozens thousands hundreds of buildings
have been destroyed damaged in many
cities in the southeast of turkey and of
course across the border in the
northwest of Syria we've got reporters
in a number of cities and they have told
us about the devastation that they have
seen and the fact that in many places
The Specialist equipment those with the
expertise of trying to get people out
from collapse buildings have yet to
arrive so people locals anyone with
equipment is being employed to try their
best to remove some of the rubble and
see if anyone is beneath collapsed
buildings now the International
Community has a promised lots of Aid and
assistance that's coming from all around
the world
including Aid and rescue teams now the
UK is sending 76 search and rescue
Specialists including sniffer dogs to
the region the EU has activated the
Copernicus satellite system to help with
emergency mapping
India Japan South Korea Israel and
Greece have also announced they'll be
sending rescue teams and China has said
that it will be giving 5 million pounds
in emergency rescue Aid
well earlier I was able to speak to the
foreign office Minister Andrew Mitchell
about what the UK government's doing to
help right the aid budget is under very
uh considerable strain but but Britain
always carves out a certain amount to
cope with humanitarian crises that is
what people in Britain expect us to do
Britain is always there uh first and in
strength to help when these appalling
catastrophes take place and we will be
there this time and the humanitarian
budget is is in a way slightly separate
from the steady state International
Development budget and it is there
specifically to respond to crises like
these but to be clear any Aid that goes
into Northwest Syria will have to come
through turkey through the gilbertosua
crossing border you're not planning on
bringing Aid directly into the northwest
of Syria it's very difficult to get Aid
in we will use anything we can to to get
Aid to people who are desperately needed
and we're talking uh and closely
coordinating with the United Nations but
if you look at the geography the the
weigh-in is from Turkey it's over that
border which is very restricted and
that's an additional problem at a
desperate time for people who've already
suffered so much in Northern Syria
well here is uh
more of the devastation that has been
wrought by those earthquakes in Turkey
this is the city of which is a city of
some 1.1 million people and it's always
worth remembering when looking at these
shots of these cities of Devastation
that this is a single shot showing
perhaps one building that's collapsed
but as we understand from the reporting
the scale of the devastation in Turkey
is vast whole neighborhoods have been
destroyed a Turkish president overnight
announced there will be seven days of
morning Flags would be flown at a half
mast as some 13 000 people have been
deployed to try and assist with the
rescue operation
now this is diabaker where the rescue of
course continues many Cyprus Sandler
foreign
in turkey and across the border in Syria
Aleppo Latakia Hammer have all been
affected by this earthquake now at the
point we understand that some 4 700
people have died but that number looking
at the scale of the destruction is
certain to rise in the coming days now
the first few hours of these kind of
disasters are vitally important and the
effort will be of course continuing but
with freezing conditions and the
difficulty of getting assistance and
heavy machinery and experts experts in
pulling people out of rubble into the
areas where it's needed
the situation remains very challenging
for people both in turkey and in
Northern Syria
but the world has decided to send Aid
and send equipment and send Specialists
and send money to try and assist both
turkey and Syria in their efforts just a
day on from those major earthquakes and
just to highlight the sense of seismic
activity in the region at the moment
another 5.7 magnitude earthquake has
just been reported in the last 45
minutes but the rescue effort continues
teams Specialists and non-specialists
anyone who is able and willing to help
have been spending the past days
combing through Rubble of collapsed
building as thousands came down as a
result of those two major earthquakes
yesterday the death toll at the moment
stands at 4
700 unfortunately it's expected that
number will rise will of course bring
you all the latest on the earthquake
throughout the morning